[Music]
hello, how are you, 3 gonzález greeting you with
your brief information for today, Wednesday
, July 7, this news is still
developing, a woman is under arrest
for allegedly running over a man
with her car, and according to reports it was on
purpose, this happened a little earlier
at 2 and 30m in a neighborhood east of
power station the police said the
woman hit him and fled the scene
however she was located in a
residence near the scene
the victim was taken to
hospital and is expected to survive
and if you are looking for a job
this might interest you the city of las
vegas will have a job fair for the
safety
program this program offers
extracurricular activities before and after
school for local students
there will be a fair today and Thursday
starting at 8 a.m. and  30 in the morning
until 3:30 in the afternoon
[Music]
starting tomorrow everyone who
has at least one dose of the vaccine
against e  l cob and will be entered to
win prizes backs nevada
days winning prizes will be announced tomorrow
these include phases to state
parks cash and up to one million
dollars winners will be drawn
randomly and each week for a total of 8
weeks through the 26th  august
and now we go to see the weather forecast
we will have hot temperatures
for today reaching 114 degrees we
will stay in temperatures
above 110 for the rest of the week
so remember to drink plenty of water
stay out of the sun for several hours and
Above all, take care of your pets and
the children. He wishes you an excellent day.
3 González happen and this was the
eimish now newscast in Spanish
[Music]